c'est un déjeuner sur l'herbe revisité
en inversant les rôles de l'oeuvre de
manet ce tableau met en scène un homme
nu entouré de femmes habillées reprendre
l'histoire de l'art avec humour jocelyne
brise l'est en a fait sa spécialité
j'ai repris donc des velasquez des
monnaies des manèges
ingres j'essaye de faire parfois de
l'ironie et j'accompagne donc cette
référence ça peut être un comment dire
un extrait de l'oeuvre pas forcément
l'oeuvre en entier et je la compagne
avec une peinture que qui est peut-être
plus contemporaine bien sûr que celle de
l'époque une quarantaine de ses toiles
ont investi l'espace de covile elles
dialoguent avec les sculptures des
vagues aux tic et sa recherche sur l'
équilibre
j'aime bien les tensions qui peut se
montrer dans ses positions là la
sculpture je peux la positionner
différentes manières c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de
particulièrement frontalité il n'y a pas
de fall s'il n'y a pas de côté on peut
regarder on peut prendre la nana est
regardée de tous les côtés et on peut la
pause et aussi dans différentes manières
elle peut être aussi bien comme ça ou
comme ça les deux artistes amis depuis
20 ans ont monté cette exposition
ensemble une discussion entre primitif
et contemporain à découvrir jusqu'au 5
mars